hello everyone and welcome to another
game from round one of the 2018
candidates tournament and in my opinion
this is the most interesting game that
happened in round one and it's between
the new rivals LaVon Oregon and the
Dingle earrin as you know two of them
faced off in the finals of the World Cup
in police' Georgia last year and after
draw after drawing for classical games
it was only then that eleven are in and
managed to win both of the rapid games
taking first place in the world cup but
placing 1st and 2nd both of them
qualified for the candidates and now
they are playing here and what I want to
know about this game is how much of it
is exactly Aaron's home preparation and
what what was found over the board and I
know everyone when you see Aaron is
playing you wonder how quickly in the
opening is he gonna play h4 well to
answer that question we have to see the
game and I didn't want to I considered
showing you some photos of the two of
them actually playing but a gun is very
strict about you know you can't just use
any of their content so I decided it was
best not to so sorry about that but
maybe maybe next time
Aragon opens with c4 the English opening
we have Knight to f6 Knight to c3 and a
six we have E 4 and now d v e5 d4 and
now he captures on f6d captures on c3 be
captures on c3 and Queen captures on f6
this is all pretty standard and here
Aragon plays d4 and here you have a lot
of ideas for black you could attack the
center immediately would e5 you could
attack it with c5 but Tingler and
decides to go b6 he wants to play a nice
a nice game play Bishop to b7 bring this
back to d6 Castle King side and maybe
but it's already in this position and
this is move 8r engine doesn't want to
have anything to do with this
he plays h4 and I have I have I mean I'm
I'm definitely sure h4 is a home
preparation move and that he really
found all the poisons of the position
but as you'll see in the game this
position is so poisonous that
all of his home preparation couldn't
possibly help him there the ideas of
course are the immediate Bishop to g5
attacking the Queen rook is coming to h3
maybe it will be an aggressive piece it
maybe it can be used as a defensive
piece that is as it will protect the
pawn on c3 for example so a lot of ideas
here for white but dinkler Erin isn't
afraid of any of this he simply
continuous Bishop to be 7-iron young
goes for Bishop to g5 now attacking the
Queen and Queen to f5 this was played in
the game this is the only good move
playing Queen to g6 would simply give
white to too good of a position as now
after Bishop d3 the queen is attacked
you don't really have anywhere to go
with the Queen I either have to ruin
your pawn structure with that five or
you have to play Bishop e for but if you
play Bishop three four then h5 is coming
Queen to a5 g4 and now you have to
capture the bishop Queen captures Bishop
captures your attacking the rook on a8
and after black defense here Queen to a4
and black a white has an excellent
position so a ding leerin doesn't go for
this
so after this Bishop to g5 movie plays
Queen to f5 and now we have Bishop to d3
and again Bishop to g4 isn't an option
because then g4 is coming and h5 and we
reach the same variation we just showed
so Queen to a5 and what's the Queen
doing here well now we have to really
see what's going on here I'm sure this
is all still our engines from
preparation
the queen is attacking the pawn on c3
this would come with check so there's
that and the bishop is also eyeing the
g-tube pawn so how do you how do you
prevent this here are young played King
to f1 if he played it relatively quickly
so I'm sure all the way to King f1 I'm
sure this is still home preparation and
now you don't really want to capture
this pawn and c3 if you capture Queen
captures on c3 then you just allow white
to develop fast or 92 is coming out
Queen has to go back and the Queen is
still very uh no five and the white will
simply continue developing you can play
something like rugby one break open with
c5 a lot of things to do here with white
and black is pretty passive so after
this
to f1 move nuclear and decided to simply
develop Knight to c6 and here we have
rock to be one and again rope to be one
is a very interesting idea but you'll
see why it's interesting as here again
you don't want to capture on c3
nothing's pretty much changing the
position you're only gonna allow White's
to develop faster but capturing on a two
would be a pretty pretty big mistake
because now after rook to a-1 you have
to go Queen to be two and now Knight
comes to e2 and now how do you play this
position with black let's say you want
to cast so first you have to get rid of
the light squared the dark square Bishop
so let's say h6 Bishop goes back and now
you Castle to protect your c7 pawn but
now you are losing this game because now
rook to a forest coming rook trade for
being played and now there is no defense
against the bishop to c1 trapping the
Queen even if you try Knight to a5 to
prepare Queen so b3 is protected it
doesn't doesn't really matter Bishop to
see one queen bee tree and a bishop to
c2 and the Queen is trapped so a lot of
poison in this position and I'm sure are
an uncovered all of this in it in his
home preparation so Tingler in place if
f6 he gets rid of this extremely active
Bishop Bishop to d2 and now queenside
castle and here Aragon plays a four and
now you can see this is move 14 and
you're playing white this is move 14 you
have opponent a for you have opponent h4
and you have a king on f1 so if you
don't really know what you're doing
you're going to lose this game but as
you'll see White has a lot of potential
in this position here ding Leon please
ePHI which is a great move as he wants
to open up the center Arendt's King is
awkwardly placed on f1 f1 so you have to
punish this somehow here are an
undecided to play c5 and c5 is again a
very tricky move as it prepares rook to
b5 now pushing the Queen even further to
a6
so after c5 dinkler and decide play
Bishop captures on c5 so what's the idea
here
well if you capture the bishop then you
lose your own bishop on d3 because it's
protected so here rook to b5 first
pushing ding Lorentz Queen even further
back Queen to a6 and now rook to h3
finally making this rook lift now the
rook is also guarding the bishop on d3
Saudi captors on c5 is definitely a
threat but Dingley rain is not afraid he
plays a Bishop captures on d4 so what's
the idea here
well if you capture at CCAP force on d4
you get rook captures on d4 and now what
do you do here and what's the idea the
idea is now that the rook and the Queen
are attacking the a4 pawn and black is
actually black actually doesn't mind
giving up a piece for so many pawns
Knight to e2 attacking the rook and now
Queen captures on a4 Queen captures rook
captures and here ding Liron would have
four pawns for the piece and out of
those four three are connected passed
pawns
so black would be better in this
position so a lot of poison to it so
after this Bishop captures on d4 first
iron and plays Bishop to e2 now now ding
leerin really has to find a move and
here in this position he played rook to
d6 I caught a glimpse of the live
coverage by young Gustafson and Sopko
guru miss really worried and said that
he cheated he looked at an engines
proposal and the engine suggested Bishop
to a8 and it's true when you consider a
move like Bishop to 8 it all makes sense
now after arguing continues Ruby - you
play Queen to b7 and now you have this
beautiful Queen Bishop battery I think
that g2 pawn so now if you play pawn
captures you get Knight captures and
it's really it's really questionable
does white have the advantage for his
extra piece here because that extra
piece really isn't doing anything and
black is really active but okay it's
hard to say if dinkler and saw Bishop to
8 or he just didn't like it he decided
to play rook to d6 and here are again
played rook to be 1 and this was the
position this is the position you really
have to like put on your board or you
can use it as a diagram on your on your
screen and
really study it because it's extremely
complicated and there are a lot of
things that can happen here here
basically what they did was like I said
rock to be one now
there's an open discovery and England's
Queen Queen to a5 was played and here
are n repeated rook to b5 Queen a6 rock
to b1 and queen a5 and the rook to b5
and it was in this position that both of
them agreed to a draw but why is this
such a great position to study because
after this rook to d6 move by the
England okay are indeed play rook to be
one but the thing you have to see that
after this rook to be one the queen is
attacked but instead of rook to be one
can Aragon capture this Bishop on d4
well not really
if you capture the bishop then you don't
really gain anything black can simply
play Knight captures on d4 and again
your rook is now attacked on b5 you have
to you have to take care of this and
after rook to be to then Knight can
capture on e - so black pretty much
solved all of his problems
another thing is rook to be one isn't
that the best move Ireland could play
best move here would actually be rook to
be - because after the following
variation Queen now has to move Queen to
a5 and now after C capture Sundy for
your queen is attack seems like a good
move for white but now black has Queen
to d5 and now whatever you do black is
either threatening to capture on d4 or
if you capture with the pawn on e5
Knight captures now you again have the
bishop queen battery on g2 but now at
least your Bishop on d2 is not attacked
as I mean it is but the row can be too
is defending it that's why rock to be -
would have been better than rook to be
one but it seems that this part of the
game wasn't in Aaron's home preparation
but again after your defenders would
neither three and the rock is coming to
d8 it's it's I mean it's very hard to
say
can white really make use of his extra
piece in a position like this but that's
not the end of it after this rook to be
one move
we said Queen - if I was played RN
repeated Bishop rook to b5 and here
again Queen to a6 was played but there
was also a possibility for Dingley and
to bravely go where no man has gone
before but he had to play Bishop
captures on c3 but I'm sure both are an
unending Liron were extremely happy that
he didn't play this as this position is
simply too complicated now if you
capture blacks Queen then you're losing
the game after rook captures and e2 if
you try to save the Queen then Bishop
captures on a5 and with two rooks two
powerful bishops here and the knight
black has more than enough compensation
for the Queen
Black is better here on the other hand
after Bishop captures on c3 the move you
really had to find with white is rook to
d3
now the bishop on d2 is no longer
attacked three times but now rook
captures Bishop captures and this is the
moved England had to see if he was even
to consider playing Bishop captures on
c3 Bishop to a 6mm and now this is again
extremely complicated if you play rook
captures on a5 then Bishop captures on
d3 comes with to check if you block 92
then you get night to d4 attacking the
pin piece so King to e1 but now Bishop
captures Queen captures and now again
one more move the England had to see
before he even considered entering this
variation is rook to d8 and now you're
protecting your bishop and this rook has
nowhere to go
the bishop is covering a6 the rook is
now covering d5w also covering b5 so
white is also now losing this rook
better to grab something than nothing
and after Knight captures a5 probably
and white with a black would have a
bishop and the rook for the Queen but
with with a lot of pawns up not a lot
but would have pawn up it would
definitely be a better position for
black so yeah I mean as such an
extremely complicated game and here
after this rook to d6 move definitely a
position for you to really enjoy and try
to figure out all the variations as you
can probably stare at this for
like an hour and still don't figure out
what's going on on the board so
definitely the most beautiful game in
the most complicated game as you can see
that even with wood even with a lot of
home preparation you still can be ready
for anything that happens on the board
so yeah that's the game our onion versus
doing liver and I do hope you enjoyed it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon probably with
Tolliver's the Botany game 6 thank you
all and see you soon